parts of the southern plains are under
tornado watches this morning more than a
dozen twisters hit Texas Oklahoma and
Kansas yesterday there are no reports of
injuries Mireya Villarreal is in Mangum
Oklahoma one of the towns where there is
significant damage me.they a good
morning hey good morning guys we are at
the County Fairgrounds this area took a
direct hit you can see the roof has been
sheared off of this building also the
walls the framework they are all gone
three homes in this area were destroyed
as well as an apartment complex we also
know we were on the heels of the tornado
that hit this area and it was moving
fast yesterday a massive twister tore
through Mangum Monday shredding an
entire home sending debris flying
through the air you see it just coming a
little closer and finally my husband
says we're gonna have to go somewhere
another tornado nearby shattered the
windows and damaged the roof of this 112
year old home and tore this building to
the ground I couldn't believe it you
left it a half hour earlier and it was
all there you come back in it was big
lately
demolished one of the only things left
standing from this house and Perry was a
car parked in what used to be the garage
and a near Crescent Oklahoma these twin
tornadoes spun just about a mile of
heart the severe storm also brought
heavy rains and hailed the size of
Marvel's people in LaPlante Louisiana
began to survey the damage where at
least 50 homes and businesses were
destroyed and gas pumps were torn
straight from the ground fences are down
car parts are gone tin flying through
the air porches are gone but all of that
can be fixed
they I'm just saying hallelujah anyhow
because no one was hurt there are
reports winds hit at least a hundred and
ten miles per hour with this storm
system we also know again there was some
severe damage but no injuries in this
area so that was a good thing there will
be crews out with the National Weather
Service later today to figure out
exactly how strong this tornado was gale
Matea thank you pictures not pretty
thanks a lot